jungle baby
I'm gonna be space traveler
space travel
wait so avenge not being a DJ has its
downsides go to bring equipment whatnot
with you and you know the rest of the
crew just got their backpack and they
can go run off after the show I've go to
Karen guitars and stuff around building
my muscles which hasn't happened yet but
you know rock music will eventually
defeat all djs Yemen I like going to DJ
advance I like moombahton I like Diplo's
work it's kind of strange to fly to them
though because they kind of give you
this look of what's that thing you're
doing up there you know you're rushing
something off your chest with your hand
like what is what's going on there and
we just want to hear some wobble bass
but you know I love all the bits as much
as the next guy but
we got to do your guitar thing a little
bit open your open your mind like Cueto
says I just listened to a lot of Records
and kind of let it just ate and make
imprints in my brain and then up pops
these crazy songs I don't know where
they came from then other people can say
what they are I don't even know what it
is what other band would i play with
yeah go go big ah go big I don't know I
don't really like a lot of big bands but
i would like to play my useless leaders
but I'm may be useless skeeters but now
I don't like them but like I have no
idea I like I would like to play on top
of a building by myself sometime there
you go I dro that's really something
really social story i'm gonna play a
suicide she wants play suicide
unemployed Rihanna
I'm gonna be space traveler
spits traveler